oh guys look we just got a delivery here
yeah this is gonna be awesome
[Music]
[Music]
that little sucker actually goes pretty
good it does about five miles per hour
with both boys in it but we can make it
faster
no hey
[Music]
were those little cars fun yeah yeah
well I think we need to do some upgrades
starting with Nerf guns
we're gonna take this Nerf blaster it's
the Prometheus it's the largest most
powerful Nerf gun money can buy right
now and we are gonna modify this and put
it on that car damn you excited yeah
run
[Music]
so much fun dance monkey
it is so much more accurate than the
dart gun this thing holds over 200
rounds in the hopper and it takes
seconds to reload it's also got a
rechargeable removable battery pack so
this thing is just awesome
foreign
this is the guts of the Nerf gun you've
got a little motor here that feeds an
auger and a conveyor belt that takes the
balls from the hopper and puts them in
between these two spinning wheels and
they spit out the balls the same way a
pitching machine does you've got a
little switch in here this is where the
hopper clicks into place and it won't
work if the hopper is not properly shut
and clicked into place you've got your
battery housing right there and up in
here you've got a series of switches
there we go if you have these two
switches here this one revs the spinning
wheels here
and this one moves the augers here but
this one won't work unless you're
depressing this switch so
we got all the switches free for the
handle there's our low battery light
we'll put that aside for this to work I
need to replace this switch and this
switch unfortunately these switches have
like three wires coming out of them the
switches I want to use have two wires
coming out of them one of these wires is
connected to the motherboard and I think
the motherboard is not necessary so I'm
going to chop it off and see if it still
works and if it does great if not huh
we're gonna have a problem let's see
what happens when we cut it
mmm
well that went well let's cut some more
wires and see what happens I'm much less
certain about what to do with this
switch I need to get rid of one of these
wires this is the negative to the
battery this is the positive to the
auger motor this goes to the switch that
detects whether the hopper is installed
so my best guess is we clip this one
I don't know why there's these extra
wires but it still works
okay that so now we've removed the
motherboard and the low battery
indicator light all right that is the
gut make sure it still works
[Music]
it still shoots first things first we
need to build a new housing for this
thing
foreign
[Music]
this is the hopper switch unless it's
depressed the whole thing doesn't work
so we're going to just go ahead and do a
low-tech solution
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
uh now all we gotta do is make another
one ta-da
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
so I really want to put a rocket
launcher on these cars it'll shoot these
Nerf missiles so I've got an electronic
solenoid hooked up to my 100 psi air
compressor here and we're going to test
it out and make sure it doesn't explode
and kill the children
it went just as far as I was hoping and
it didn't explode that's a success
[Applause]
there we go
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
there we go
good
okay I got the rocket launchers up now
I'm going to install a two and a half
gallon air tank to shoot the rocket
foreign
[Music]
look at that we got 100 PSI
that went over the bush all right guys
you ready to go test him out
okay head on up the hill
[Music]
finish the rocket launcher got all the
leaks fixed it holds 100 PSI and uses
about one PSI every time you hit the
button it'll shoot Rockets down to about
20 psi so you've got about 80 shots with
one tank now that I've finished with
that Beast I've got to modify this one
and I'm gonna do something a little
different
foreign
this is a 12 volt battery
and we're going to replace it with this
24 volt battery
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that's juicy
foreign
a 24 volt battery in a 12 volt car isn't
that complicated but you have two
problems one is it puts a lot of wear
and tear on the motors especially when
you're accelerating because the pedal is
only an on and off switch it's not like
the gas pedal on a car the other problem
is that it'll give the kids Whiplash and
it'll pop wheelies and stuff because all
of a sudden you hit that pedal and
instantly you get 24 volts of power so
all these complicated Electronics solve
that problem first off this knob puts a
delay on the acceleration so there's a
one second delay where it takes one
second to go from zero to full speed or
you can go five seconds from zero to
full speed so it accelerates gradually
the other thing it does is it has like a
dimmer switch here which can govern the
maximum voltage use you can either use
all 24 volts or you can go at fifty
percent use 12 volts or 25 percent and
only use six volts so depending on the
age of the kid and the train you're
using you can dumb it down we're going
to hit it at 75 percent and two seconds
to start off with
oh my goodness
[Music]
you're doing burnouts I'm gonna make it
accelerate a little slower
and I'm going to take the power down
just a little bit okay
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
holy mackerel that's Juiced up another
modification I made to this is a kill
switch so if the kids get too far or
driving too dangerously I can remotely
turn off the car
[Applause]
[Music]
these are wonderful I got to figure out
how to install these into the children
um I might have wired that wrong all
right we have the second car tricked out
now we got to add some guns and I'm
gonna do some more modifications for
this one instead of modifying the
housing I'm going to be modifying the
guts
instead of completely gutting this like
I did the last gun I'm going to Simply
give it alternative methods of powering
it alternative triggers and alternative
flywheel triggers come on there we go
all right let's give this a quick test
[Music]
it's getting really hot now why is that
stop and reevaluate what have we done
oh this battery is melting whoa yeah
this is making noise let's get this
outside something is up with that well
the battery was smoking and overheating
which is what happens when you take a
wire and you hook up the positive
directly to the negative of the battery
so I'm guessing what happened is that
one of the wires associated with the
auger switch is creating a feedback
where the the electricity is going from
the battery back into the battery and
that's what's causing the problem so I
think I need to clip some of the wires
that I clipped before and I think it's
the brown one let's try
that
all right so we learned a valuable
lesson definitely definitely cut the
brown wire
now we mark it all right that's the
battery
ah darn it I screwed into my fingernail
I'll just wipe my fingernail blood and
goo off my drill bit and we'll keep
going
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
all right I've got the plug for the
trigger the flywheel and the battery and
I've Got Each one with a different
connector so I can't accidentally get
them crossed this is the Lipo 3s battery
I'm going to use to run the gun and LiPO
batteries you do not want to over drain
them so I've got a voltage alarm that
I'm going to plug in here and let's
and just for a little extra safety I'm
gonna put the LiPo battery inside uh
fire resistant pouch there plug that in
let's see what happens oh we got one
more modification for the gun this is
the stock Hopper which holds 200 balls
this right here was 3D printed it's
called the god Hopper it holds about 2
000 balls and uh
slides in
like so check it out it's got two
spring-loaded ports back here for
dumping balls in and this thing is a
beast one final Edition an ammo can with
extra Nerf balls this thing is loaded
[Music]
here Tom get over there Troy
whoa
holy mackerel that thing's on steroids
that is uh that is a powerful thing
right there
yeah my band The Leah there you go man
yeah I think we're ready to do a Nerf
battle
[Music]
s
okay yeah
all right guys you ready to test this
out
all right go for it
everything
[Music]
that was so cool I keep watching Nathan
in the neck
[Music]
foreign
yeah
yours is smoking good yeah Tommy's back
wheels completely seized up
there we go
[Music]
well we burned out with her Tommy's
motor and we used up all the battery on
Nathan's car but we had a great time
didn't you guys have a great time yeah
yeah what oh
well guys we ended up shooting about 3
000 Nerf balls and a lot of you are
wondering how on Earth we're gonna clean
this all up I've got a trick this
parking lot only has two storm drains
and we covered both of them up with wood
3 000 rounds and a little bit of trash
picked up in no time at all but I gotta
get these cars home and work on
upgrading Tommy's gearbox if you'd like
to see me use these cars in future
videos make sure to click that like
button so that I know that this is
something you guys want to see also
shout out to Adam Savage with the
YouTube channel Adam Savages tested if
you ever want to make a Nerf weapon mech
suit you know just give me a call email
me something hey guys did you have a
good time yeah
if you guys like these types of videos
we've got tons of building projects like
the floating fishing cabin we did a few
months ago and we've got tons of Nerf
war videos too if you like that sort of
thing so definitely click subscribe we
put out new videos every Saturday
morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
you guys working on the cars there
yeah